welcome back to CBS this morning and
only on CBS this morning we're hearing
for the first time from a Utah boy who
was subjected to a homophobic rant by
his substitute teacher the teacher who
was later fired berated the fifth grader
for being adopted by two men Louie and
Josh Amstel officially adopted
eleven-year-old Daniel just yesterday
and we sat down with the new family to
discuss what happened in class last
month it was a controversy that started
when the teacher asks the kids what
they're thankful for I am thankful for
my dad and dad my family my dogs and
everybody that I love with now what
makes them good dads they disciplined me
when I do bad things they help me they
keep me out of trouble and they give me
sometimes what I want they love you too
I imagine
Daniel van Amstel has lived with Louie
and Josh for six months but when he
mentioned his pending adoption at his
elementary school outside Salt Lake City
what happened the teacher insulted my
family what did she do well she first
said why would you be happy you'd be
adopted by them and that's when one of
the three kids ones in my class place
they stuck up for me and said let's stop
but she kept going and she said are you
gonna be gay are you going to be in I
have no idea what was it like to hear
the teacher say that there's something
wrong with them honestly I went red I
didn't like what they she said what does
that mean you went red I was very mad
because is it not it's not right nice to
insult other families even if you don't
like them if you don't have anything
nice to say don't say it if you could
talk to that teacher now what would you
tell her I would tell you should have
made better choices in life Louis what's
it like for you hearing him talk about
this incident
okay tolay louie who you may recognize
from Dancing with the Stars says Daniels
been through five foster families and
one failed adoption and was fearful this
one could be in jeopardy too so he also
became read at school because of I don't
want to get this teacher in trouble
because if I get in trouble my parents
will not adopt me so he stayed quiet the
girl stood up for him he was just
sitting there quietly answering the
questions and looked really scared
classmates Demi and Sophie say they
couldn't stay silent all of us were
uncomfortable and so like I didn't want
to be any longer in that situation and
so I just had to stop it Sophie tried to
change the topic in class and Demi went
to the principal's office a bit scared
to go in there but after that I know I
was doing the right thing the principal
removed the teacher and called Josh our
child had been bullied by a superior by
somebody who was brought in from the
school in order to teach these children
5th grade math 5th grade and you know
English she's not there to teach
semantics she's not there to teach her
her personal religious views the
staffing company she worked for
apparently agreed they fired her how do
you feel about that
I feel she could have done better even
if she didn't like it she didn't have to
say that but I'm glad she got her lesson
taught that's called Karma
so we did not say this is him but it was
Louie who took this conversation public
when he shared the story on social media
we are not letting this go all of this
is happening against a backdrop in which
the Trump administration is trying to
make it acceptable and legal for
religious organizations to say no to
same-sex couples who want to adopt
looking just that this picture would we
be people that agree with that no look
at this young gentleman that would still
be in the foster care if it were up to
them is that what they want have you had
a chance to talk to the substitute no we
don't know her name we don't know who
she is
but I would love to have lunch with her
and sit down why not I do not like her
ever Soler again I'd probably have a
heart attack no you want why would she
ever say what she said to him before she
actually met us if we're bad people and
we still we do bad things then she can
have an opinion about that but because
we happen to be gay before she met us
now I've loved at lunch with her what
did this whole experience teach you
about your family about your school
about your kid it doesn't matter what
family you have it just matters if you
love them or not
and yes I do love them Wow oh my god
that's beyond sweet number one daniel
was so wise beyond his years as it is
Jamie and Sophie to come to his defense
yes they did and they so they all
articulated how they felt so really
genuinely and so smartly it's a very I
love I love hearing about a heroic
moment in a classroom with me and Sophie
you know see that Daniel is struggling
and take it upon themselves to change
the conversation and it's very brave
yeah and Louie Josh the fathers they say
yeah let's talk about them too they're
also great they think that this teacher
was acting out of a sense of Ed of a
religious intolerance but what they want
to point out is that that's one person
and it's not the whole religion it's not
the whole religious community and in
fact those the little girls who came to
Daniel's aid also part of a religious
community but they made a distinction
themselves yes I mean it shows you that
family comes in all shapes and forms and
they here to Tony they had been to
several foster homes trouble and Lou and
Josh are hoping for more yeah like that
like that in school can be so damaging
it's so fortunate that they made the
best of it yeah positive story in the
echo
you